all right Deandra
DeAndre where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
um I grew up in Visalia
um when I was younger I was born in
Downey uh California and I
grew up
um between Visalia and uh San Gabriel
Valley
tell me about your family
my family
I haven't seen my family
together in about nine years
I can think I think the eight years
like think I don't think I've seen my
dad in about
14.
oh you describe your childhood in
general
very very very difficult
what kind of stuff was going on
well
um at seven years old I well I'm a time
traveler so at the eight like when I was
younger I dealt with
um leading the Renaissance and coming
into my body as a child in the new era
which is was like late in the 90s
um so when I was a little girl it was
very hard for me
very very hard for me
because I had to leave the Renaissance
and then I had to come to the New
Millennium or this you know the late 90s
early 2000s and
um I had to leave my kids and my husband
um who was Mark Wahlberg
um in the Renaissance
this was how old were you when this was
going on
um seven years old
so your childhood with your family was
lots of hypnotizing I was hypnotized all
the time by everything
um
despite people trying to kidnap me and
me getting
uh
dropped off by [__] weird the women
in my family were were very confused
um they didn't know how to handle a lot
of this this stuff
um neither did
none of them knew how to handle this
period being around me
um because I was constantly getting
cursed and I was
you know just it was very everything was
hard everything was so it's been hard
um I having the only way I was able to
have fun was what my parents would make
me forget things
so
I put you in school
I didn't graduate high school I lied
about it and said I did but I didn't
graduate high school I stopped going to
school when I was a junior I was in
early junior year
what'd you do after that
I
I was on the street
you've been on the streets ever since
yeah
um I was I I had to
find a way to find myself to connect my
two worlds together and um
despite all the cursing and all of the
things that the people
were doing to me
um I found I I forced it
because
I feel like I didn't have a sense or
purpose
I feel like I didn't
matter
I feel like or I felt I feel both
like the they took the something worth
it in the sky for granted
who um when I sing in the sky I mean you
know how we have everybody has their god
well my God
I don't see
but my God speaks to me and he also
speaks to her
who
is
[Music]
um
I can't see who she is because it's not
something that you're not allowed to
talk about in our community and
um
it's just
I forget things like I'm already
forgetting things like what by but I
don't know why but I feel like losing my
train of thought huh
my ears are full
I had a I'm I'm saying whenever I get my
nose and my throat and my face gets like
this that means I'm getting crumb I'm
being cursed
so
did your parents ever
put you in touch with a mental health
doctor or anything like that oh yeah
I've been in and out of Mental Hospitals
my whole life
what a day
find I can't hear you but what did they
find did you have any
anything that needed
mental health medications or treatment
or anything like that
oh yeah was there any for any diagnosis
oh I'm sure you can ask them
I mean I was always appeared fine I mean
yeah post-traumatic stress disorder from
stress from my mom
look what was going on with your mom
when you were a kid
well I was being cursed by her 24 7.
people get off on cursing me you know
that's it's it's uh it's uh it's an
epidemic people who curse the South
America but when you curse her you have
to deal with the consequences for
cursinger
and when you
do curse
someone with all the power in the world
you have to really think about what
you're doing what you're whether you're
doing it for yourself or whether you're
doing it for you
what I mean is your inner God your outer
God your inner God is supposed to be
inside of you if you're cursing for your
inner God then that means that you look
at yourself as God
okay I don't look at myself as God
because I know who God is
um I know his powers he gives me my
Powers
um
I
what are your powers
my power comes with connection I can
connect
um
I can see
look at someone and I can already know
their intentions I don't need a sidekick
I don't need
I don't need anything
to uh
to really tell me
what you know what what what your what
your intentions are what you're doing
who you are as a person I can already
see it I can already see what like
what you're trying to accomplish
and do you have children now
yes I do I take care of uh oh around 200
children
over 200 children
these are your children or something my
children I have 39 of my own kids
and uh 39 39. yeah that I've had I had
uh in the Renaissance and that I brought
that have stayed
with uh their father in
and out of Haiti
but uh Oprah Oprah has them at a ranch
she takes childhood to take care of her
sorry Oprah you Oprah's yes she helps me
take care of my kids Oprah Winfrey Oprah
Winfrey helps me take care of my
children because I am it's not the worth
it and I give people the best and the
full
their heart's desires I fulfill dreams
for people I make things happen but they
have to believe within their heart who
they are
um if you are
going to be like the transvestites that
cursed and raped me you're gonna get
what you pretty much what you're what
you're setting out to do
and
I think that people who do that to me I
think it's funny because they're asking
for a lifetime of misery and a lifetime
of misery and and in time traveling
times is endless
them you curse yourself when you curse
me it's rhetorical
so that's I don't curse them but when
you curse me
God says that God's gonna tell me what
to do and I don't need to do anything
because he takes care of the cursy
I don't need to curse when you curse me
it's automatic rhetorical like your feet
if you if if someone over here is is is
doing something that they know is a
trigger and it sets me off or that sets
that that is the like length that are
just common that people set up curses
everywhere I go set up every curses
Everywhere I Go
and you know and and it's it's just
something like that when I got sealed oh
and when people try to break my seals
they end up in in prison in where
Therian prisons and I already have I had
I just retake I'm queen of Transylvania
so I really don't have to worry about
anything anymore so when you when I
reclaim being queen of shoes Maria is
when I took back a Huerta that they used
to curse me and the people that I love
okay so when you do that and you're
cursed CVA you thought you were gonna
trap me somewhere else all I did was
fall asleep and take it back
with the help from White voodoo
how old are you now de younger
36.
where do you stay what does that have to
do with me being clear as well yeah
you're all over the pool like are we
going to do like an interview like
talking about like like what like this
like whole thing or like do you want to
know about me because like I mean if you
want to know about me I'll tell you
about me but don't mix two of them
together because they're two separate
lives I'm sorry okay what would where do
you stay now where do you
well I don't know I just got out of
huerte I've just got out of tent on the
street or you're I just got out of
puerte which means that I just got
finished sacrificing
before I came to see you
okay
are drugs a part of your life
there's not even anybody's business
where would you like to be in five years
I'm already where I'm at
I don't need to look for towards my
future I've accomplished the ultimate
goal which is
meeting Jesus
having G is this curse with us
that's the ultimate goal
for me
how many people have you
were Jesus cursed
Jesus doesn't do you okay see people
that ask that that say stupid things
like that how many people has Jesus
cursed okay I think you said earlier
Jesus does what God wants okay there's
okay you know the hierarchy in heaven
because I don't think you know the
hierarchy how it works in heaven okay
there's God there's God's Kings okay who
he has a set of his 12 disciples his 12
disciples oversee
everything okay if you were a chosen 12
disciple you
have to protect the Sanctified woman who
protects her who protects the dead okay
the Sanctified woman who protects the
dead is me I was chosen by those 12
disciples
and God
a very very long time ago before time
before people cut into my [__] time
and uh did it and cut out hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of years
I don't have something to my eye
um that um you know that's
that's how it goes and if you get
between that if you get if you think
that you're gonna overrule God his kids
and his his hierarchy of anything that
he's got not to mention Satan curses for
me as well because Satan is my brother
okay so you have to remember that I am
in between this and this okay and not to
mention Hades my husband my ex-husband
okay so I should say distant husband
because we'll get married to Haiti you
really don't ever leave him okay who's
Haiti Haiti
whose Hades whoever you want him to be
I can't give you a name
so in between those two things you have
to remember I I travel between I go here
and I go here I'm a good person so I
float I have to float I have a chance to
go like this
okay so with that
I really I can say that it is a blessing
and it is the most exciting and magical
thing that you could ever ask for to be
blessed by a Sanctified Queen
from the heavens and the fallen angel
from from Below it is a blessing to be
in the presence of somebody like me
because
you have a chance to ask for everything
that you want
and you have a chance to ask for
your wildest dreams as long as they're
Within Reach of you know not beating
pedophilic and disgusted disdained from
you know from the people of the world
will you if you see that you're going to
ask me to feed into your flesh I'm not
going to do that but what I'm going to
do is I'm gonna have a talk with them
and they're gonna say honey this is what
we're gonna do
about this what can you tell a story or
two of what you've I cannot tell a story
because the story isn't true
I can answer your questions and that's
the best I can do are there any
examples of how
what you're describing ask me something
is there anyone that you've met that
you've affected like with your disciples
and you've been affected you mean have I
changed lives exactly you want to know
about Christina because sit here and
talk about cursing people that's stupid
anything that you would like to talk
about
oh you're the one who feel asking the
questions
I mean you want to know about these
things and I'm telling you but don't ask
me to tell you how to curse that's
that's stupid I'm asking how to do it
I'm just asking and don't ask me about
about about how to find these people
either because I'm not going to tell you
that either to find anyone and don't ask
me their names because that's just
stupid
it's like so like it's just common you
know I
don't don't insult my intelligence
please I'm sorry
do you have any friends
I have I have quite a few acquaintances
she's not really a friend though I have
friends but I got taken away from my
friends so I haven't got to see them in
a very long time my friends got cursed
by the disgusting people and they got
dragged in to Coming to America and got
dragged into being in a place because
people don't like to land their own
[__] business and so now I have to go
and I have to make sure after I get a
week or two of rest because I haven't
sleeped in two years
um I have to go and check on these
people because these people decided to
go and help me which means that they
stopped sacrificed for the South Dakota
by sacrificing their lives to come and
help me
and you were chosen at what age like
when you were a kid or by before you
were you don't get chosen it's like
you're God it's this is a well you're a
time if you're a time traveler you know
better like like why would you like
foreign
traveler
no I'm saying I've never met one before
that's all I'm saying so you're not a
time traveler
I guess I'm not
stuck right here
oh those are ads are gross
I'm sorry nothing
of all the times that you have traveled
what has been your favorite
I haven't got to travel I haven't got to
oh like it depends where but I haven't
got to travel I haven't got to go
anywhere
and what I do in my dreams is private so
I'm not going to have a conversation
like that with you because I can already
feel like I just can't I can't trust you
so
how do you uh survive on the streets how
do you make money I don't have to
survive in the streets
because I'm not in the streets where do
you stay
out of your business I don't stay
anywhere I walk around 24 hours a day
seven days a week
unless I'm getting kidnapped or held
against my own will
but that probably requires some money to
eat or
I don't
I don't I do without you don't I do
without when I sacrifice
and when I come home
I hope that all my sacrificing was worth
something because you know what I got
everything that was mine even in my lot
of all the things that I had given to me
were cursed to
five transvestites where's home
you said when you when you go home yeah
hope doesn't have anything to do with
what we're talking about right now
what do you think most people don't
understand about time travel and
all the things you're describing
I could care less if they understand it
or not I know you don't care but I'm
just asking I don't care about [__]
people and the things that they have
like I have to say because like [__]
retardation is just something you're
born with okay if you're [__] and
you're ignorant I can't take that away
from you unless you ask for it so I
can't take away your retardation you're
ignorance so and I'm not going to
because this this is like this is
[__]
I will be doing this because I thought
this was going to be somewhat like
helpful for some reason I don't know be
helpful to those listening
what would you like to share
I think there's a lot of people that
don't understand a lot of the things
that you've described okay so if they
don't understand it then they need to
sit with the Cardinal and or or a priest
and ask
there's nothing you can do to Enlighten
anyone oh I don't I'm talking to you so
this is about you not me okay is there
anything you can do to enlighten me
because I I seem to be very confused as
to what you're describing if you're
confused then maybe you need to talk to
a priest okay and will you talk to your
priest you come and talk to me okay
because I'm not somebody that you really
want to just jump and have a
conversation with because until unless
you're ready and you have a map of your
do your your your due diligence list and
your your your your will
I'm just trying to learn before and
after
I'm sorry before and after no I'm just
trying to learn
okay well and I'm trying to explain it
to you so that's what you have to do
because by you jumping to me and
skipping a whole lot of steps and it's
gonna do nothing but probably hurt you
instead of which I'm gonna give you a
pass this time because you're naive
but I highly suggest that you talk to
your your priest about having the next
conversation or interview with me
because
you
aren't uh
your your knowledge is very is very
minimal about the woman who I am very
okay so I'm just going to give you a
piece of advice and if you want to have
a conversation in the future after you
are done talking to my the guy who I who
who who works with me or my children or
you know my hierarchy of you know
Cardinals and Priests that are in the
church you know or kings and queens you
don't think whoever I have a lot of
people that can refer you to somebody
that you can have a conversation with
before you come to me because if you
come to me it's like you're shedding all
your dreams and everything that you ever
thought that you have your future you're
just you're asking it to go to hell
by doing that okay so I'm going to give
you a piece of advice and I'm going to
tell you that and what do you get
all that figured out you come and you
talk to me you say since our first
interview and since our first
conversation this is what I think so I
may she may have should have done this
or I shouldn't have or however you want
to take it okay
but I'm gonna give you a second chance
and I'm gonna give you you know the
option to do a little bit more research
and since you know I just you know got
out of sacrifice seed now you're not
knowing so much about me
um I'm going to give you a chance to to
to to learn about me okay appreciate
that thank you that's the most I could
do for you I appreciate that tell me
about your kids
I like to keep my family private for now
because uh I'm not asking about anything
no I know I just just because you don't
know me I want you to go talk to
somebody before I've never met anybody
who has how many kids 200. like I said
before you say anything else that's
gonna ruin your second chance in having
a conversation with me I'm just gonna
suggest that we like we stop here okay
but if you don't if you want to like
talk to me off camera
I can answer some questions for you but
it's just I just don't see
I just I don't want you're only gonna
get one chance with me okay and I I'm
gonna give you two people don't get two
Chances with the Santa huerte okay they
get one
okay
that's all I'm gonna tell you right now
so please be wise okay do you would you
like to talk about murder you're calling
it
I think I think we'll just we should
just pause it right there if if you like
I said if you will turn off the camera
you want to talk that's fine but I just
don't think that
if you want to talk about something
let's talk about
what's the date today
is the
the 14th of January okay and how long
have you been here in this in this is in
this establishment I've been here for
maybe half an hour no I bet like here
like working here like I've been here in
this studio about four years has anybody
come in and like have done uh any
interviews with you like about like and
had talked about me never never no okay
well that's good
um because like I'm just curious to know
like what like what you know about me
before you start asking me like about my
children no you just mentioned you had
yeah because I thought you had knowledge
about me but now I know you don't I
don't I don't know anything about you
okay I know nothing about you except you
told me you had hundreds of kids so I
found that interesting
for 39 kids I think you also said you
had
is anyone else in your family chosen
like you are
I'm not going to ask to answer that
either
I'm sorry I'm not going to answer that
would you like to talk about or you feel
like we're done
when I was sacrificing
I was
raped I was kidnapped I was held against
my own will I was
hurt by a lot of people
that looked up to this
you know you know I want to tell I have
something to talk about when I was a
little kid there was this guy who
followed me around all the [__] time
in and out of worth it and his name was
Nettie and you know what he did he
terrorized My Life as a child and he
would kidnap me lock me in bathrooms
make my parents forget where they were
because he would hypnotize people
into getting what he wanted
okay now when he would hypnotize people
I'm talking about he would find out some
of the most disgusting and sickest ways
to get something from somebody
and what he would do to me is to get to
be
he would take me so he would have me
killed
and then when I would reincarnate he
would bring me back in a tent
15 years prior to the date that I was
dead
back in time and then would seal off the
area so that way my family couldn't find
me
my children had to watch me get raped
my children had to watch me get
kidnapped in torture town
so if that's something you want to know
about that's something that people need
to know about I'd love to know more
about that that's something that people
need to know about
What would
you like to talk about that
before I didn't think that I like like I
was too sensitive but now it just makes
me [__] angry because this people
think that like the uh what they call
the Netter Community
um they think that they're good people
and they look up to this this guy who
there was a guy
who's a good person right who uh who I
really can't talk about but there's
another guy with the same name who's a
bad person
okay now I know who the good one is
because he's my friend and that's all I
can tell you but this bad guy
whose name I already gave you
got blessed with all of these gifts and
I would like to know
who gave him my gifts
to come in and out of an area that is
for for people who who this is not the
one that needs uh who protect her and
that you know
she protects them
how did these people get in to invade my
space
where did they learn all this stuff from
because if it is
something that
whatever secret society I'm gonna find
out about whatever these people are
doing that that he curses before himself
or whatever all that other [__] it's
disgusting and whoever does
affiliate themselves with that [__]
is going to end up
in the river
of death and when I tell you the river
of death
it is a river that Haiti has that
Spirits go in and they don't come out
and will your spirit dies your body will
follow
and
people need to know people need to know
about
what they're getting themselves into
when they support people who rape this
other word and who hurt her and who
trapped her and who do all these things
to curse her because
this
I have armies
I have lieutenants I have generals
I have people
all over the world
who will fight for me
and I'm talking about from the King of
England
all the way back in the Renaissance
all the way till now
what does that tell you
ambassadors presidents
all over the world I have
historical
historical amazing
characters and people who have who have
got to survive because
we want a war
yes
I had all these things happen but if
they think that they're going to
continue to do it I don't think so
I don't think so
I don't know I just I just I really I
really I really confused as we help
people
think that they're like
past and present is gonna come to a flow
very soon so what I mean by that is
there's going to be people
from
the biblical days who are who who have
reincarnated
in and and and progressed into time
traveling who are still going to be
alive
which means I'm going to use the three
the three guys the from the Bible as an
example of Matthew Mark Luke and John
okay
I'm not gonna say
that it's true and I'm not going to say
it's false but I'm going to say there's
a chance
a very good chance that these men are
still alive
you're gonna get a chance
what advice would you give to the
the people watching this that don't
quite understand
everything you're describing
what do we all need to know more I think
the best advice that I could give
everybody
is um protect your family
um
whatever religious denominational
religion you are
I I think that the the most important
thing is that if you want to make sure
that you're safe
all I need you to do is ask me to
protect you
and
I will
it takes it this easy I'm gonna tell I'm
going to teach you guys how to do one
thing all you need to do is seal your
home okay and when you do that you can
get any have your mother or the woman or
the man of the house together put
together a fragrance or a type of mist
water
uh holy water we'll call it holy water
because we all all the um all the
religions of the world have their own
holy water okay use your holy water in
the quarters of your house to seal it
and what that can do for you is that can
ask you're asking me to protect you and
your family and if you give you the
chance to do that
I promise you you will not be
disappointed
because I will protect you and I will
protect your family
because God has given me life after
death so many times
it would be my honor to be able to
protect every family in the world
how many times have you died
more than 2 000 times
you've had a rough life yeah very
yeah but you know
up until today up until now
I think that before where I felt like I
didn't have a purpose
now I have a purpose
I have a purpose what do you think that
purpose is
save the world
one person at a time
it's a noble cause to protect everybody
just as any
bad person
would try to violate some good person I
don't want that to happen ever again
because the war of Good and Evil has a
hero in that zero is me
and I don't say that with
with pride I say that
I say that with hope
that I can continue
to help
rescuing souls and helping people and
saving diamonds and giving them back and
doing all these amazing things because
if I can do it
I really need a lot of helpers
that means that I need a lot of help
to be protected
it's so just my hierarchy in heaven and
hell you can't do it alone I cannot
and I say hell very lightly because you
gotta remember Haiti deals with a lot of
with all the people who have hurt all
the good people in the world
just like all the good people go to
heaven
that is a beautiful place
it is the most amazing place you'll ever
go
to be a
to be aware with the word that the
community likes to use is where they're
in okay
um to be a we're there in time traveler
with uh the future of the hope of a
nautical marriage with my family
um
is only one's dream
and if I can continue to share it with
the world that's what I'm gonna do but I
don't want people to give up on getting
to know me as a person
and ask yourself
Deandra thank you so much for
thank you sharing your thoughts on and
all this and uh I appreciate it maybe
we'll do this again yeah that'd be right
I'd enjoy that all right thank you all
no problem